سلسله اتهامات جديده القى بها قائد فاجنر
متحدثا هذه المره عن العاب خطيره تمارسها
جهات داخل اروقه الكرملين لتدمير الدوله
الروسيه وبث الفتنه فيها
بريجوجين حذر وهدد من انه في حال دب
الصراع بين فاجنر والقوات الشيشانيه فان
الرابح محسوم لكن سينتج عنه حمام كما قال
صدقني لو حصلت مواجهه بين قوات فاكنر
وقوات اخماط الشيشانيه سيكون النصر لنا
لكن سيؤدي ذلك لاراقه الكثير من الدماء
فصائل مجهوله من داخل الكرملين اتهمها
بريكوجين بفتح صندوق بندوره لزرع
الانقسامات على حد وصفه
ليؤكد من جديد على ان الخلاف القديم مع
المقاتلين الشيشان قد تم تسويته بالفعل
الخلاف بيننا وبين المقاتلين الشيشان قد
تم تسويته لكن الاقتتال الداخلي في
الكريملين فتح صندوق بندوره من الانقسامات
عاصفه من الاتهامات اللاذعه شنها قائد
فاجنر على وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ايضا بعد
ان تعرضت منطقه بيلجرود في الايام الاخيره
لقصف وهجمات مكثفه
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ما يحدث
في منطقه حيث يتم الاستيلاء على اراضي
روسيه فمن الواضح اننا سنتدخل ولن ننتظر
دعوه او اثنان للانتشار في المنطقه
اثار الشد والجذب المستمران بين قائد قوه
فاغنر والنخب الروسيه تساؤلات عده بشان
طبيعه العلاقه بين الكرملين والمجموعه
العسكريه الخاصه
واصط ضبابيه العلاقه بين الجانبين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات